hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bigfoot a funny
thing happened just yesterday i
literally finished hunting bigfoot and
the moment that i closed the game
there's an update literally as i was
playing
and hunting bigfoot there was another
update to the game that not only updated
the ai of bigfoot
but also created a whole new map at
yellowstone park so i thought why not
try it again so i'm going to go back in
and i'm going to make this a challenge
because i'm starting to get the feel
of bigfoot that's not something that i
should say out loud i'm starting to get
to feel of hunting bigfoot and i'm going
to make it more difficult i'm going to
increase bigfoot's health
damage and i'm going to decrease the
loot amount to almost
nothing and in doing so i'm hoping that
i'm going to be able to hunt bigfoot a
little better and this time i'm going to
get
rick
because i have a funny feeling i'm gonna
need all the firepower i can get and he
gets 10 firearms damage and then 10
melee damage so if things get
down to the nitty-gritty i may have to
uh
throw hands with bigfoot and i don't
think i'm gonna get a lot of ammo but
it's all mine and if things go right i
should be able to hunt bigfoot
yellowstone national park is known for
its lush vivid landscapes the
tranquility of the park brings peace to
all visitors the powerful geysers have
become a trademark attracting thousands
of tourists from all over the country
the wildlife only adds to the
experiences of yellowstone any camper
can go out on their own to track
wildlife and see them up close there's
even a cave that predators are said to
frequent if you're lucky enough to find
it so we're going to go back in now last
time i ran into a problem where i didn't
have a lot of traps now to be honest i
don't want to use traps unless i'm going
to be able to put a lot of damage into
bigfoot surprisingly yellowstone is far
from tame just a month ago two
volunteers from greenpeace avery and
luis were found dead in one of the
clearings they had been in the park to
clean up litter and beautify the park
but something had been wading from the
woods for them and had ended their
mission early was it just an unfortunate
accident or something more it's up to
you to find out which
i got a funny feeling it's bigfoot and
i'm doing this with night vision again
just because i find it a really
fascinating experience it makes it just
a little bit more immersive for me and
it makes it just a little bit spookier
and now that i know that bigfoot is more
dangerous
i have a funny feeling i'm going to have
a pretty tough time with this
not to be overly dramatic about it i
don't want to do that
[Music]
oh my god look at this map
that's a big ass lake okay so i have a
funny feeling if i get to that lake i'm
not going to be able to cross it
and i also don't know what any of the
landmarks is this is a brand new map i
don't even think this was in the older
version of bigfoot
so it's all on me i gotta do what i
gotta do to survive which means kill
bigfoot pretty much
all right
nothing there
oh my god did i
were there traps there in the other map
and i just didn't grab them am i that
big of an idiot am i that bad of a
driver probably okay i'm looking for
louisa and avery
and there is in fact the bigfoot around
so if this goes like last time
he's not going to be here the first
night but the first night is gonna roll
around immediately and that means i
gotta get on the move so i gotta hurry
up also it said that there was a new
animal i don't know if that's a
dangerous animal i hadn't run into
problems yet but that doesn't mean that
it can't happen
okay five five six
all right that looks like everything in
the camper except the food
i don't know why i want to take meat on
me i think that does just draw him to me
yep okay and i won i gotta be more
mindful about traps in the middle of the
trees because i keep running into them
and yes i'm so far so good at the quick
time events but that doesn't mean that
i'm gonna
do good forever i'm gonna put cameras at
the crop
i swear that's bigfoot setting up a trap
that has to be right
it seems like a good vantage point
all right that's one
reload
oh that's not a lot of bullets that's
not a lot of bullets i'm gonna head
south across the river
continue onward
avoid bigfoot
hope for the best it is a bit i see here
i'm gonna put another camera right here
good crossroads
and there's a totem not that i need it
but i'll collect it i guess i still
don't know if it's bad for me to do this
but i'm taking it
i have a funny feeling that if you
collect things that are supposed to
revive your friends if you had friends
if you're out in the woods and you
actually had people that joined you
which i don't and maybe it might draw
more attention to yourself i really
don't understand the
full nuance of bigfoot's ai
not that that matters
fuel cancer that's good shotgun chills i
don't have a shotgun yet but
ammo is good
uh
that's something
[Music]
i don't like it
okay well that's
that's probably not good i'm definitely
bigfoot didn't throw that i should
really focus on just scouting the area
not intending to do a lot of damage
right now because any damage that i do
is probably going to be healed back up
so i just got to be mindful
of my ammo and hurt him only when i can
do damage which is gonna require a lot
of self-control and a lot of evasion
so i'm gonna just shoot
all right good
oh hey yay
god they don't know this place
i don't know this place
[Music]
moose
moose
oh moose i don't want to mess with a
moose a moose is bad news a moose a
moose could kill you a muse a muse could
kill you dead it could kill me dead and
it definitely could kill you dead if it
could kill if you could kill me
it definitely could kill you so don't
mess with moose musai musan
a flocka mooson that just goes to the
lake there i don't know if there's gonna
be anything i just don't know this place
i don't know if there's gonna be cabins
like the other one cabins were really
nice because it could hide in cabins and
i don't think any any kind of like
mechanics of the night you know the
first night him not hunting is gonna say
is gonna save me if i just so happen to
run into him
you heard that right oh i don't like the
rain
oh i don't like the rain okay yeah this
is a big ass
god i hear something this is a big ass
thing
i see lights across the lake i'm gonna
[Music]
i true it i hate it
i hate it it's gonna load up my flare
gun not that i should use it but i i i
don't want to die oh what is this
just a
wrecked boat
uh too slow in the lake i doubt
bigfoot's any slower in the water
there's no zip line across the water oh
this is terrible oh this is awful
oh this is awful i don't have enough
bullets oh i couldn't do anything i
can't even like throw them off with
bullets
no
no
i hate how much noise i'm making in the
foliage
oh my god oh my god is that a moose is
that a moose is that a moose
oh my god is that a moose
one i don't see anything
oh my god
oh my god
i heard a moose i do not see a moose
they're so big how do they hide
how does a moose hide
oh it's a buffalo
that's even worse
no it's not worse i don't know i i oh
god shut up
shut up
i don't like it
oh
awful awful awful awful awful actually
i should probably look up if i want to
avoid the traps i'm just really stompy
when i run
it just sounds like there's footsteps
all around me but i think that's by
design
unless there is a bigfoot around here
and then i'm in trouble
there's a totem there
okay
oh my god
god
i hate that i hate all of that i hate
everything about that it's day time now
i'm safe but i only have one day cycle
to get some stuff and i still haven't
found any kind of a shelter i can fight
with
in around on is there nothing here more
meat good great
oh this was useless oh why did i come
here okay
why did i set the loot so low
i gotta find another gun or i'm boned
oh moo is that a moose is that a moose
please run away from me moose do not
charge me oh it's a deer okay that's
fine oh daytime all right that's helpful
i gotta make some progress i'm not
living up to the honored
bigfoot research association
i'm not living up to their standards i
don't think i'm gonna be living for much
longer at all actually oh god why don't
i have a telescope why haven't i been
setting it on cameras
let me set down the camera i'll do it
when i get back to the main road there
not that i think bigfoot sticks to roads
really but
better than nothing
okay well that's a problem hard to get
out of the river
the realism i too would struggle to get
out of a river in fact i think a raging
rapids would just sweep me away into
nothingness and i would die
oh he's being crappy
oh stop birds you burn bastards oh my
god
okay so this is the park entrance
um let me just do it at the first
intersection a camera at the first
intersection here
that'll be good enough
got a good field of view
perfect
i am so whoa hi buffalo
i am so
screwed okay
that could have killed me
that's fine
that's fine i'm just gonna ignore that
come on there's no buildings i must have
just gone the complete wrong way
uh something
shelter yeah shelter this ain't gonna
stop nothing let alone a big foot
nothing
nothing
nothing
nothing oh
absolutely nothing unless i'm missing oh
here we go okay eight four five four
looks like a red eight four five four
got it okay that is something good thing
i double checked but i look like i'm not
gonna
the chance of me actually getting to
that safe
and being able to punch that in very low
very low okay we got a canoe a bridge
and a whole lot of nothing
and
sun is moving okay we're about halfway
through the day a little less a little
more oh here we go
okay all right
this could be something
yay
oh 12 gauge if i can only i could find a
shotgun i've got so much meat on me
oh man bigfoot's gonna love me
a little more ammo
just a little more ammo and
some meat that's about it
not a good shelter to fight in that's
for sure i gotta keep moving
i'm getting
supply drop hey can i get some can you
draw me a supply
can you rescue me please all right down
to the edge of the lake here i'm going
to save my cameras i want to put three
more on the north side if i even get
back to there
oh that's not good
should i take a picture of that
nope i don't care about that just a
bunch of human bones that's no problem
that's fine
not worthy of a picture if you ask me
just an ordinary day in
yellowstone with that ooh building
holy crap i found a building
i wouldn't believe it oh it's been
destroyed good
certainly a bigfoot has not been here
uh-huh oh warm and inviting
another fuel canister i can't take that
i might
try to fight him here if i've already
got a fuel canister sitting here and the
windows are boarded up and another truck
and the red
8454
oh my god oh my god
okay that's good oh my god that's a lot
of bullets
holy crap
okay i think i'm gonna try to hole up
here
because i've got an escape out the back
i've got first aid kits
i'll just close that for now
close that for now this might actually
work out okay what i'll do
is he's gonna come here so i set up the
fuel canister to hit him with that
right about here
so i hit it out the door and definitely
still hit him grab this one
i could hit it from there
okay we're getting dicey we gotta make a
decision okay he's definitely gonna be
coming here
so why don't i do it like this
set up this my trap here
and the front door and set up the second
fuel oh a gas bottle that'll be even
better but i need somewhere i can hit it
from the back end of the hallway let me
actually take that
here
so he's definitely going to be hit there
so i should be able to hit the gas
bottle right as he comes in leave the
door open maybe i could circle back
around twice go out go in close the door
get a few more shots off
oh god oh god oh god maybe i should
close that
i should probably close that door
no
i should close that door
i should close that door i'll hit him
through the window bigfoot
bigfoot
oh come on
where is he
he's not popping up i don't know why
it's not popping up
oh my god
what the hell
oh this is nerve-wracking the update
said it changed some of his behavior
so he may not behave the way that i
remember i haven't got a single blip on
any of my cameras not that they're big
coverage but they do kind of cover the
weight to me god for some reason this
feels like dark wood right now you know
when it's night and you have to hole up
and board up the windows and you just
sit and wait in a dark corner and you
hope for the best god that was a good
game i hope they do a sequel to that
just very fun survival
aspect of it i just enjoyed the going
out and getting supplies and coming back
it was very fun
that's got to be just traps that has to
be just traps that's traps maybe i've
done a good job hiding myself
maybe hiding yourself is a thing you can
do
[Applause]
oh god am i do oh my
oh
god
god
oh my god you son of a [ __ ]
well that sounds close well that sounds
close
wait no no
day
day
day break did i make it
i forgot to relay my trap i guess it's
day now okay
i can't take that because i got two but
that's okay oh i hated that okay
um i guess i'm gonna go i heard a lot of
trap making
in the night i'm assuming that there's a
lot of traps i don't know if you can see
them if you look up or whatever but that
was terrifying that was one of the worst
nights i've spent
in the woods
waiting for bigfoot to come kill me
yeah so something's different about the
way he behaves i don't know what and i
don't know how
but it's different
and so i don't know what to expect going
in but i know that there's a fire
canister there not that i think i'm
gonna circle back across the map ooh
another building
yeah i don't think i'm gonna go back
across a map to try to get to it but
oh there's a whole bunch of stuff here
ah this is like the center town i should
have known by the way the roads went
where is it wait i see one building i
see a water tower it seems like this is
a town okay grand village that sounds
nice ooh there's smoke
people must be here and alive and well
and very happy oh this is lovely
oh this is lovely oh that's not lovely
but this is lovely
help yeah help me help me
help me i'm very skilled
uh the problem with these is i don't
think they have oh they do the window
okay
all right that's good that's not good
another trap i'll take it 762 ammo
ah man i really did make it sparse here
storage a microwave is storage sure i
hear rope
i think that's a that must be a trap to
the left
some kind of a trap that definitely
sounds like rope of some kind
i don't trust that see if i can see what
it is
definitely hear it okay i'm gonna try to
i'm trying to gonna try to be on the
lookout for that sound so all of these
could be good to fight in
because i can run out the back window at
least
and i can buy more time with all the
traps that i found
which is good
baseball bat i finally have a melee
weapon
good
great gas cancer already have one okay i
should definitely fight here if there's
gonna be the gas cancers but i don't
know if he's gonna be coming
oh
he's doing it again
i hear that oh
whoa
oh
no
no
oh god oh god wait what whoa whoa whoa
not good
uh
don't like that okay
so if there's a fuel canister there was
a gas canister in the other one i'm
gonna make this the fighting place
and try to do as much damage as possible
right here oh man sun's already going
down okay um let's see you had the gas
canister so what i'll do is
i'm gonna set up one
right
here
because i can see the window from here
this will be the first place i go
and then i'll set up a trap inside
so that after i oh my god okay all right
are we going are we going i i didn't get
to i didn't get to do
anything i didn't set up anything
trap there so i can get out the back it
buys me enough time
maybe i should put some meat on debated
where was that okay he's coming he's
coming oh he's coming
oh it's only now night three what are
you
oh god oh god here we go
where'd you go where'd you go okay come
through
come through
come here you
where no no no no don't what are you
doing
what are you doing
[Music]
what
what well that's not how i
remember him behaving i guess i could
do another
trapping in
another place
is he did he give up is that something
that he can do now he can actually be
scared off well he healed up most of the
damage that i did with that one
explosion i am
so confused
i am so confused
i am incredibly confused
oh what in the world what in the world
what in the world
what
earthquake
bigfoot taking a dump what happened i
guess it is yellowstone it's supposed to
be a seismically active
place okay he must have left i mean i
did blow a gas canister in his face but
i guess he left
oh god oh god oh god
oh
okay this is much dicer than i thought
it was this just got me holed up in a
house you got me stuck here just because
i'm scared to go out
that's not fair that's not fun i'm brave
i'll fight you
i'll fight you i'll fight you i'll fight
you
have i been in here i think i've been in
here definitely been in there there have
i been in the center one door's open so
i'm assuming yes but i see
something here
okay maybe this is different no i've
been in here have i been in here i don't
even remember any yeah that guitar looks
familiar
i know there's got to be like traps all
over the place there's no way that
bigfoot was not
oh my god oh my god
oh that's thunder
god this rain is messing with me i keep
thinking that thunder and stuff like
that and rumbles and anything is like
his stumps stomping up my way but
apparently not yeah i'm brave i'm not
gonna hold up forever
i gotta get moving day's breaking
we gotta go
there's no place to be for long periods
of time
oh he's peeved
okay okay
i think
oh god where was that oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh no no
no
holy [ __ ] is he coming
no
i think he was just moving
but he god he's nearby
just gonna head out
this uh oh that's uh
is that all faithful that's cool
that's fun
oh nice
makes me feel like i'm not gonna die
imminently
it gives me some hope after all well
bigfoot didn't like the bathrooms
maybe he just thinks humans stink
wouldn't be wrong
oh yeah
plenty of first aid
[Music]
oh god i heard it way too late
i didn't even notice it i didn't notice
anything on the ground
maybe i don't think if i look up i see
anything like that i think it is just
the
the sounds of rope though
just got to be careful
oh i hear another one
it could just whoa ho ho
all right then
yeah it could just be the trees you know
futson
hunting tower
stay away from the trees i mean really
it just should be a policy stay away
from the trees
trees are no good
ammo and a car battery good
it's more stuff to trap all right i'll
put a camera on this crossroad here
god so bright
it's almost like it's not horrifying
i i now i just hear creaking everywhere
so i'm thinking that it might just also
be the trees and maybe it's just
completely random
all right building here
oh okay
um magruder magruder rangers house what
does that even mean what is a magruder
ranger
that's something i should know
an extension to the bigfoot research
association well another place to fight
i guess probably has a safe in it i bet
nope honestly no
big axe okay
gps sensor i should do that next time
more flare guns that's always good that
looks like it not the best place to
fight that's for sure is the sun already
going down
please tell me the sun is not already
going down
that is so incredibly unfair oh my god
the sun is already going down great
and i have
a cabin
oh
god no thank you
[Applause]
well this doesn't have any doors
well this is incredibly inconvenient
well this does not bode well for me
this seems like i'm gonna die
just getting more ammo i'm gonna have to
start shooting him
eventually if you just give me oh my god
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
no
no
no
oh
i'm out in the open
oh my god
oh this is terrible oh this is terrible
oh whoa oh oh oh oh oh please
yeah hit my trap hit my trap
oh my god
oh you're on fire
weird
that's fun
and
oh my god i'm out in the open
come at me bro come at me you want some
awesome
yeah come on come on come on come on
come on oh trap came back okay cool
oh yeah where are you come on i'm out in
the open
come on
oh now it's the night
it wasn't the night before
now it's the night you're done
you're done
you're done okay
fine
all right
i'm not gonna hole up anymore
i know what i'm doing
i'm part of the bigfoot research
association i'm not
gonna
cower in fear
when i can take the fight to bigfoot
i'm the one hunting here
what was that
heard something
oh it's a fox oh it's a moose
okay
oh
it's a movement hang on
not a car battery
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh god get out of here moose
get out of here moose
okay might have been leaving
quick look
okay
i think we're good
weirdly enough i think we're good
oh my god
car battery place it down
oh my god no
no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
oh no
oh
my dude
oh
my god
that could not have gone worse
where are you where are you where are
you where are you
where are you
where are you
where are you
where are you
oh god i'm in the river i need to reload
my flare okay
and i need to not miss my flare
yeah yeah
yeah on this bridge on this bridge on
this bridge right here you can't go
anywhere you're on this bridge this is
me and you
where you at let me set off the
fireworks
hello oh there we go
beautiful
come on
come on
right there baby right there
and right there come on i'm gonna put
some meat on it for you
really well this son of a [ __ ]
is that how this fire works for nothing
it got way too quiet
it got way too quiet
oh my god
that's definitely a trap
huh i knew it i knew it i knew it
i don't even understand how does it
how does it trap me
how's the trap even work
is it the leanie trees
is it if you go under the leani trees i
don't know i don't know anymore i don't
know anything
i'm just trying to live i'm just trying
to
survive
survive
i'll try surviving it's like eternal
night awful
horrible are all these leaning trees
traps
oh hi oh my me
run away and now it's day
he
bigfoot behaves differently
definitely very differently
more uh strategic instead of just
barreling straight into me every time
which honestly i would like the stupider
bigfoot
just turns out the yeti is a little bit
dumb
i'm gonna try to make sure i stab him
with a gps sensor next time i'm full on
ammo
i am absolutely full on 762 ammo i
didn't think it was possible but i is
oh go why here why here oh no why here
oh don't like that
hello
hello
oh blue's safe okay so if i can find a
blue code not that i've been paying
attention
another trap always love that
not that i've really been using them
very efficiently
four two five eight
love you oh yes
yes okay that's gonna help me with the
uh consumption of this ammo
because i have a lot of it
if only i could find a shotgun oh
oh my god oh god okay hold on everybody
hold on
i'll be right back
oh my god i'll be right back
ah
[Music]
what
i'm alive
oh
i'm alive
how in the hell am i alive
ah
interesting i thought i was gonna be
dead for sure um trap is completely gone
right
uh so
unfortunately
i ran out of time
i don't think there's a oh there's a way
to save
i don't know how i survived that okay
but i'm alive so what i'm gonna do
just in case i'm going in here i'm
saving and unfortunately i can't
continue now but i have a lot of weapons
and i have a lot of stuff so i'm going
to say oh my god i have not healed i'm
gonna heal
i'm just gonna heal full and then i'm
gonna save
and i will continue this
i don't know how i survived
but i did so that's good
thank you everybody so much for watching
i'll pick this up
in just a little bit
thank you
and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]